random planets the only way we'll know
this guy is smart is if he has a
well-worn famous philosophy book in his
hands
also glasses pop deep do we need to go
7,000 feet that's all over India for
this thing used to be the deepest cup of
mine in the world this rickety elevator
travels 11,000 feet by the time dr.
Satnam finishes one sentence the
neutrinos are causing a physical
reaction that's impossible
sounds like it to me too unbelievable
view of capitol building from hotel is
unbelievable
this is a black-tie event I agree that's
a stupid rule but this news is so urgent
that Adrian couldn't put on the proper
attire before he got here black-tie
event but no black-tie required as long
as you have a jacket you need to read
this sir you need to read it now guy who
doesn't take this scientists seriously
decides to look at the report because
the scientists yelled at him there
really was a g8 summit in 2010 and while
it was in Canada it was in Huntsville
Ontario come on Hollywood
you made this movie after this event all
he had to do was Google Danny Glover
isn't too old for this scene mr. mock
Arrancar wishes to have his interpreters
present mr. president I can assure you
your English is more than sufficient
except in the areas where it's not I
can't really know your English
vocabulary but I'm sure it'll be fine
also his translator is translating this
sentence how can his English be good
enough for any conversation if he can't
even understand mr. president I could
assure you your English is more than
sufficient for what I have to say the
world as we know it will soon come to an
end well at least he's not being vague
about things I sure I'm glad this movie
keeps reminding us what year it is in
every scene or else I would just think
every scene is a new year and it be 2156
by the time the movies over
oh I thought this was the da Vinci Code
for a second is this again also this
movie is only just now starting I'm a
dead man it's so refreshing to see an
irresponsible divorced dad in the movies
I'm glad this guy's so messy that his
own books are strewn across the floor in
a manner that we can find out he's a
writer Jackson Curtis isn't in a horror
movie yet but he has all the cliches
down after one minute of screen time Wow
good thing Jackson is a limo driver
these days or he'd have been for
transportation discount white Morgan
Freeman also end-of-the-world sign that
normally doesn't mean anything takes on
significant meaning now cliche man she
seems so nice I hope she doesn't have a
new boyfriend it was a douche bag no
lipo on Fridays every night before she
goes to sleep
well at least it's known as m'a but can
a kid just be a normal pink kid without
having some issue that the hero has to
worry about anything confounds the
pressboard oh man
apparently it's roughly the same time in
Paris that it is in Washington DC right
now if the car was supposed to explode
why was there guy driving on the dudes
tail this whole time why does the car
blow up now and not earlier man I bet
that older kid is playing video games
has headphones on and hates this shit
right now yep this happened in the
middle of the night Washington time but
the morning paper already has a story on
it I just is she oblivious that the guy
died while she was on the phone with him
only a dozen people in this
administration know what I'm about to
tell you dad what's going on
geez didn't you just hear him he said he
was about to tell you worst father ever
not only takes his kids inside
restricted area in giant wilderness Park
but then continues to just casually take
in all the surroundings even while elk
are boiling on the ground in front of
him Wow Wow this isn't even a character
they literally just filmed Woody
Harrelson doing his typical daily
routine and then used it for his part in
the movie also the director said why
don't eat a pickle it'll make you look
even crazier this is unbelievable 2,700
degrees Celsius of 40,000 feet okay I
guess that was cool with the Indian guy
telling us they were 11,000 feet
underground a minute ago but I am NOT
okay with this continued use of feet
measurement from scientists I mean I
know many of us are dumb Americans but
do we really need to know feet in this
instance wouldn't 12,000 meters still
sound deep enough let's get
sky glasses a notepad a cane and two no
three pens to make him look extra nerdy
no one in the entire united states has
ever brought up this military takeover
of Yellowstone except the crazy Woody
Harrelson guy mr. Jackson Curtis and by
proxy John Cusack is apparently only 33
in 2012 did not by any chance the
Jackson Curtis world farewell Atlantis I
did they forget to tell cue Zack the
camera was rolling he believed those
people would behave so selflessly
knowing that their own lives were at
stake
struggling authors book just happens to
have themes that overlap with this movie
how can this guy be shocked that the
crossed destabilization is happening
faster than expected especially after
the revelation that his calculations
were off just this morning the Mayans
saw this coming thousands of years ago
even in this movie it's a sin that a
scientist believes in the Mayan calendar
thank you my friend and good luck and
now cute it's amazing mosquitoes
survived for hundreds of millions of
years with this signature buzzing that
they do to give away their location why
don't you download my blog I'm pretty
sure you would never download a blog and
I'm pretty sure even this crazy
character would know that
so this is where CGP grey got his
inspiration of the planets in our solar
system that only happens every six
hundred and forty thousand years
strange that scientists have never seen
evidence of these cataclysmic events
that happen every six hundred forty
thousand years which isn't long when
you're talking about Earth's age that's
about seven hundred and nine thousand
cataclysmic events in Earth's history if
that's true orgy of evidence tells you
this asshole loves pickles oh nobody
could keep that big a secret Charlie
tell that to the people hiding Tupac
they're selling weed out for three no
guys some Russian billionaires sure he's
great that Charlie mentioned that
Russian billionaire qualifier because
Jackson just happens to know a Russian
billionaire and this will be important
later Kate picked up two good night's
packages but when her pervy boyfriend
suggests they should make a baby she has
three of them parking lot begins tearing
in half without any warning signs or
sounds making their way into the
interior of the store
you gave up med school so you could have
Noah and you practically raised him
literally by yourself pointless
exposition argument
I don't know honey I just feel like
there's something pulling us apart
devastating cataclysmic earth event has
a sense of humor also two people in the
background one with headphones before
the crack destroys the store and
absolutely no one in the background in
the next shot in fact it looks like the
whole store evacuated in two seconds
except for Kate and Gordon plus their
shopping cart had way more in it before
including those good nights but now it
has three packages of Huggies in it Kate
just downgraded her seven-year-old
daughter to toddler status ringing the
bell seems unnecessary considering that
this chick is right behind the counter a
tremendously huge chasm ripped through
the busy grocery store and not one
person got hurt or killed the magnetic
fields have decreased by more than 80
percent in the last 48 hours are we to
believe that once the president told all
these countries back in 2010 about the
catastrophe headed Earth's way that they
all just left the updates to this one
guy in the United States and didn't call
on their own scientists year he hears
his phone playing his day during the
middle of a loud boxing match while
getting pummeled in an intense fight
this box are somehow notices his friend
leaving the arena when we saw Yuri
leaving the arena earlier it looked like
he was leaving his girlfriend behind
without a word and about to board the
rich-people arc now it looks like she
caught up to him they both had a good
night's rest and they could easily have
watched the rest of the boxing match
without all the fucking drama also super
convenience ensures that regular dad
deadbeat author character we've spent so
much time with was suddenly become close
in proximity to the rest of the plot you
see this is exactly why this bolt
couldn't have been a secret for very
long these bastard kids probably told
everyone about this ship Jackson can
pick up Charlie's backwoods Yellowstone
radio broadcast all the way back in LA
missed your plane yep yeah I want to
rent it Jax it is never more than a
hundred feet away from alternative
transportation and just happens to have
an expensive watch and a willing pilot
to get this plane literal discount
Arnold Schwarzenegger no house music at
two non biblical movie has a character
named Noah and just so happens to have
arcs in it
Helios literally make it out of danger
at the very last second cliche okay I
know this movie doesn't take itself too
seriously but come on neither the
characters are in a dire survival
situation over there in the movie
airplane which one is it instead of the
much easier sidewalk charlie chooses the
path through the front yards filled with
treason
and somehow it doesn't get completely
stopped in his tracks through all that
haha
serves you right hilarious old ladies
who didn't know any better this guy has
never driven on le freeways
altering this Matta skank we've seen
inescapable damage right in front of
them but Jackson keeps finding magic
portals where there are no other cars
and no other large-scale damage to keep
driving without harm Theresa thought
they were conveniently lucky a few
seconds ago but damn now Jackson avoids
a rainfall of cars on one side and a
bridge of falling cars on the other side
seriously you should have made about a
billion dollars driving people through
time and space with this limo this movie
wants me to hate it right this entire
escape deserves about 50 more sins any
objections and a car scene was really
ridiculous thank God we're back to
something realistic the geologists
quarterbacking the end of the world
crisis from the back room in the White
House well of course he can destruction
continues to head directly for Jackson
and his family as if it's personal I'll
just see what the plane escaping the
earthquake is exactly like that other
scene with the car escaping the
earthquake you know three minutes ago an
experienced pilot eases this baby in the
air under the least optimal conditions
and it goes without a hitch
Gordon unreasonably flies the plane
through downtown LA so that we can see
all the action movie friendly
destruction Wow it's amazing what a
couple flying lessons to teach you don't
feel too bad for these people it's not
like they didn't know they lived on a
dangerous fault line
[Music]
song lyrics coordinate with the block
dad is this Magnolia is every character
related to some other character we've
already seen in this movie are you out
of your mind
character can't just have a drink
without breaking some sort of record
sobriety streak Jackson unnecessarily
takes Lily on this trip to find Charlie
Kate here's the Charlie broadcast
through the phone so clearly it sounds
like a person talking in the trailer ah
now we see why lily is here so she can
impossibly locate Charlie on the top of
the mountain at this distance while on
the phone
King Ron Wow let's see with the camper
escaping the volcano is exactly like
that other scenes with the plane
escaping the earthquake you know 10
minutes ago
shut up kid it's always following us
movie tries to out ludicrous the
ludicrous bus jump from speedy just
because this movie is unrealistic and
you're not taking it seriously does not
make it fun when the average Joe does
something so completely impossible that
one wonders why the filmmakers even
bother putting him in peril in the first
place they actually set a standard for
what speed Gordon needed to take off in
the plane 85 knots which is 97 miles per
hour or 158 km/h for all you men on dumb
Americans out there there's no way the
plane could be going a slow enough speed
for Jackson to catch up to it and then
accelerate to the speed it needs to take
off in the amount of runway they have
left
either that or Jackson is currently
running anywhere between 60 and 80 miles
per hour right now and well fuck that
she's fucking stronger than Ironman to
be able to pull him up into a moving
plane this plane escaping the volcano
scene is exactly like that other camper
escaping the volcano scene you know
three minutes ago no we're gonna need a
bigger plane movie thinks a casual Jaws
reference will get it off the hook for
all the other non John but it hasn't it
have left the people in the streets
desperately fighting for the last
remaining resources is this a
documentary playing on CNN right now who
reports like this this is racist for
both parties president's not coming he
told only mean his geologist we had to
monitor everybody who knew how do think
we kept it a secret for so long
so every scientist in the world learned
about something sinister going on and
kept it to themselves but announced that
they were gonna say something about it
so that the government could have time
to kill them she's a patient what the
girl who is coincidentally the
girlfriend of the Russian guy John
Cusack works for is also coincidentally
a patient of the plastic surgeon Q's
ex-wife is married to now
[Music]
does the air control tower care if any
plane flies out of here
I don't care they're people in the air
control tower when huge plumes of black
death are coming their way anyway this
plane escaping the plumes of black dance
is yes let's have a good laugh at the
death and destruction we interrupt this
action film to bring you seven years in
Tibet well feels like seven years at
least how did you meet Steve Goodman as
you can see not the same way you did
this is insulting to both parties please
call me Adrian you should definitely go
flirt with the president's daughter a
few moments after she found out her dad
was gonna die maybe says here's to
people who ought to be in love and it
was so the right phone lines continue to
operate perfectly for our main
characters while the world falls apart
completely ah the heavy hand of
symbolism to save some money filmmakers
resort to using stock footage of regular
everyday cruise ship disaster John F
Kennedy destroyed the White House
oh this is such a touching scene and I
just realized they've been on this plane
for 20 minutes of movie time that is an
eternity it's like the whole world
shifted by a thousand miles 1517 how do
you know that if this bolts good earth
crust displacement is messing up where
everything is then how do you know
exactly where you are and out of the
foot
we interrupt this apocalypse to bring
you alive this time with kids I don't
care that it's a life or death situation
URI is not allowing Jackson to drive his
new Bentley - car won't start scenes
with two different cars in one movie
tender sole luxury cars flying out of a
plane while Jackson drives a Bentley on
ice in child's play how does a plane
running on fumes explode as soon as the
nose hits ice this makes for an
interesting shot but I'm pretty sure
this would kill the giraffe in this kind
of cold weather and this elephant got a
billion euros well I've seen a plastic
surgeon turn out to have piloting skills
and you drove a limo through a falling
glass building so yeah why doesn't
someone have a billion euros on him
right now and there are a ton of people
who have billions of euros to throw
around I guess you really wanted a shot
at them walking with the burning plane
in the background but bullshit on that
right there here's the shot at the plane
going over the cliff again please point
out to me the footpath they would have
taken to walk down this one thing
discount a guy who throws around
millions and billions of dollars is
gonna flinch on an operation that cost
at most ten grand come on
I agree you're he's a bastard but that's
not true when you know it and our gang
is once again saved by what amounts to a
mirage in the desert a monk and his
truck random suffering in slow motion
yeah but it would be all crowded and
stuff working cellphone signal at this
point in the movie is an undeniable
middle finger to the audience from the
director the floodings can hit earlier
is that what you're telling me that why
is it a big surprise that things are
happening sooner than calculated these
changes have been happening
exponentially ever since at NAMM toll a
drain and the neutrinos were going
haywire back in 2009 every step of the
way in this movie the changes have come
sooner than expected a scientists seem
to be nice guys but they are bad at
science there isn't one person on this
planet who realized the speed of all
these things also they make Carl out to
be the big politician asshole in this
movie but given the information that he
gets from the scientists which is
constantly wrong it's hard not to agree
with the asshole decisions he's had to
make in this flick Kate just starts
speaking English to this dude like she
knows he speaks it why should I do that
and to our amazement he does I don't
know if you can understand what I'm
say oh so you do consider that people
might not speak your language from time
to time and it sure is good they hooked
up with the one truck driver who already
had the whole sneak onto the Ark's thing
planned out with this other dude my
father were here he would open the gates
well interested the dead president's
daughter has spoken throw open the gates
[Music]
China and Japan agree open the gates
impassioned plea from constantly wronged
scientist gets top politicians to open
the gates even though they only have 15
minutes to get the hell out of here but
I will remind you that we have very
limited resources and extremely limited
time actually I kind of agree with the
asshole character here look at this
stupid group of people they're still
pushing each other off the ledge over
five minutes after the first of them
reach the left do be easily solves that
how do we get Jackson and Kate back
together without Kate needing to make a
tough choice problem they have cameras
inside the hydraulics of the gate
opening mechanism seriously
our cameras locate dr. Helmsley in one
second after the order was given and
they're even able to zoom and enhance
we're headed straight for the North Face
of Mount Everest well of course you are
and not only that but the Great Wall of
China
and Stonehenge also you mean the 1500
foot wall of water that washed into the
mountains somehow formed a new ocean
that is 29,000 feet deep how the could
this ship possibly be floating at this
altitude also shouldn't all you fuckers
be having trouble breathing then I'm
bummed out my husband died but it's
really a nice fall back to have
reconciled with my original husband so
recently we interrupt this disaster
movie to bring you Titanic
a hero KITT Jackson and his son both
died holding their breath too long
underwater screaming yeah underwater
cameras are everywhere people need them
to be for any dramatic moment what an
asshole I've been this whole time cliche
oh you also it takes four digits to
express the year one we worked it out
somehow or another we all have relatives
in Wisconsin the end haha what a
terrible book but since Jackson wrote it
what a great book also what she's
sitting here reading the whole book to
Adrian even after he's already read the
book it's good no it isn't intercom
cock-blocking the waters are receding
much faster than we thought even when
there's good news these scientists can't
figure out the speed of anything yeah
Gordon actually they're called good
nights and you just lost your sponsor
Columbia movie ends with the universal
logo
[Music]
yes it's all in having the right touch
10 females to each male the women will
have to be selected for their sexual
characteristics which will have to be of
a highly stimulating nature
[Music]
let's be honest shaving sucks no one
wants to do it but it's still necessary
unless you work for Epic Meal Time but
no one wants to get out of the store of
a couple of weeks to buy expensive
razors and blades I sure as hell don't
that's why I go to dollarshaveclub.com
slash sins Dollar Shave Club is an oasis
of shaving gear in the desert of the
internet for just a few bucks a month
you can have a high-quality razors and
replace my blades sent straight to your
door they even have these one light
charlie things those are for your butt
this ain't your mama's razor and butt
wipe company
this is Dollar Shave Club in case you
hadn't heard their blades are being
awesome why are you telling me this I
don't know what if I could want to know
what look like a guy who needs to shave
and clean his butt absolutely you know
what okay fine dude what Oh have you
never seen her not with a manual razor
dude you're supposed to use the shave
butter first oh thanks for the warning
ass
[Music]
Oh No
get down